LORIN PRICE: My
name is Lorin Price.
I'm a networking specialist
customer engineer
at Google Cloud.
And today, I'm going to talk
to you about the networking
concepts for Cloud SQL
that are helpful to know
for implementation,
security, and connectivity.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Cloud SQL provides a managed
service for MySQL, PostgreSQL,
and SQL Server databases.
Cloud SQL offers many
services like backups,
high availability,
maintenance, and more,
and all managed by Google Cloud.
Each Cloud SQL instance is
powered by a virtual machine
running in a Google-managed
environment that
is connected to the environment
that you own and manage.
By running in a
Google-managed environment,
this allows Cloud
SQL to abstract away
all of the management overhead
to be offloaded from you,
the user, to Google Cloud.
Even though Cloud SQL sits in
a Google-managed environment,
Google will never have access
to the data that resides
on the Cloud SQL instance.
Cloud SQL can be deployed with
two different access patterns,
public IP and private IP.
Let's start by taking a look
into the public IP deployment
pattern.
A public IP is an
IPv4 address that
can receive connections from
devices both inside and outside
of Google's network, including
from locations like your home
or office.
Let's take a look at
the access patterns
from different scenarios.
Let's say you want to connect
from a client on prem.
To connect to a
Cloud SQL instance,
the traffic will egress
from your on-prem network
and access Cloud SQL
through a public IP
address on the internet.
If a client is located
in Google Cloud,
the traffic will egress through
an instance with a public IP
address or a Cloud NAT and
ingress to the Cloud SQL
instance through its
public IP address.
If the client is located
somewhere on the internet,
that client can access the
Cloud SQL instance directly
through its public IP.
Any clients making a connection
to a Cloud SQL instance
hosted with a public
IP must be allow
listed through the use
of authorized networks.
By default, the
allow list is empty,
and nothing can make connections
to the Cloud SQL instance.
Clients can also connect
to a Cloud SQL instance
hosted with a public IP
through a Cloud SQL auth
proxy, which we'll discuss
more later in this video.
The other Cloud SQL deployment
pattern is through private IP.
A private IP is an IPv4 that's
accessible on a Virtual Private
Cloud, or VPC.
Configuring your instance
with a private IP
is preferred when connecting
from a client with access
to a VPC, either within the
VPC or connected to the VPC
through a hybrid connection.
Private IP Cloud SQL is deployed
using Private Service Access.
Private Service Access is
a commonly used private
routing method on
Google Cloud that
allows workloads in
your VPC to access
Google-managed infrastructure
services privately.
Private Service
Access is implemented
as a VPC peering connection
between your VPC network
and the underlying Google Cloud
VPC network where your Cloud
SQL instance resides.
There are two parts to
the Private Service Access
configuration process.
You will start by
selecting an existing
or allocating a new IP address
range as the Private Service
Access range.
You also have the option
of allowing Google
to allocate the range for you.
In this case, Google will
automatically allocate an IP
range of prefix length /20 and
use the name default IP range.
If you're going to create
instances in multiple regions
for different database types,
a /20 or larger range is
recommended.
Next, a private connection,
otherwise known as VPC peer,
will be created from
your VPC network
to the underlying
service producer network.
Keep in mind that you only need
to configure Private Service
Access once for Cloud
SQL per VPC network.
And the IP range you allocate
for Private Service Access will
become available for use
by all Google services
globally that support
Private Service Access.
Let's talk through
the access patterns.
Let's start with a client
attempting to access the Cloud
SQL instance from the internet.
Because Cloud SQL is
deployed on a private IP,
there's no way
for public clients
to access the instance directly.
Now let's walk
through a connection
initiated from within
the VPC and Google Cloud.
Clients are able
to connect directly
to the Cloud SQL instance
from the directly peered VPC.
Additionally, you can also
use the Cloud SQL auth proxy.
If you are in a peered hub
and spoke architecture model,
and you're trying to make a
connection from a VPC that
is not directly paired to the
Private Service Access VPC,
you must use a proxy
due to the nontransitive
routing nature of Google's VPCs.
Be aware you can also
replace a peering hub
and spoke architecture
with a VPN hub
and spoke model, so that the
Private Service Access route
can be advertised over the VPN.
Finally, for a client
to connect from on prem,
you'll need to make sure you're
advertising the Private Service
Access route over the
VPN or the Interconnect.
If the VLAN or VPN lands in
the VPC that is peered directly
with the Private
Service Access VPC,
then you'll be able
to connect directly.
If the VLAN or VPN lands
in another peered VPC, then
you'll need to use
a proxy to connect.
Remember, you'll never be able
to ping a Cloud SQL instance.
You'll only be able to
initiate connections
through applications,
the respective database
client, or the Cloud SQL proxy.
Let's quickly touch
on some network
security-related topics.
For Cloud SQL deployed
with public IP,
you can use authorized
networks to determine
a list of whitelisted
IP addresses
that can access your instance.
You cannot use firewall rules to
control ingress to a Cloud SQL
instance.
You can use the
Cloud SQL auth proxy
to encrypt all traffic to and
from the database using TLS
and to control who and what
can connect to your Cloud SQL
instance.
So let's summarize the three
most important takeaways
from today.
Cloud SQL can be deployed
with either a public IP
or private IP access pattern.
If you want to use
Cloud SQL private IP,
you must create a Private
Service Access IP range,
and a VPC peer will be created.
Remember this when
it comes to routing.
You can use authorized networks
or Cloud SQL auth proxy
to determine who and what can
access the Cloud SQL instance.
Thanks for watching,
and look out
for another video on the
concepts of networking
for Google Cloud's
managed services.
[MUSIC PLAYING]